Title: Connect the World With Becky Anderson
- cable car vpx YT
Description: An event or circumstance in one
part of the world can have a quite significant
impact everywhere else.
Channel: 2 - CNNI
Recorded On: 8/22/2023 11:00:00 AM
Original Air Date: 4/20/2009
Transcript Generated by SnapStream
==================================
We'll be taking a deep dive into the summit's
significants coming up.
First up though, we start with the urgent
rescue mission in Pakistan to bring four people
trapped in a chair lift to safety.
Pakistan's special services group have rescued
four children so far, two kids and two adults
remain dangling in this chair lift.
They have been trapped for hours after a cable
snapped 274 meeters in the air.
The children ages 10 to 15 were on their way
to school.
We are joined now from Islamabad.
And are we any closer at this point to rescuing
those who are still trapped, Sofia?
>> Well, Becky, while it has been great news
that those four kids have been rescued, there
is a situation that because it's now night
fall and the remote part of north western
Pakistan, the helicopter rescue operation
[11:01:44 AM]
the helicopter rescue operation has had to
be paused because there is just too much darkness
there for that to continue.
So there are efforts being made by the commanders
on the ground as well as by locals to kind
of reach that cable car that is suspended
about 900 feet above ground.
And this has had the entire country fixated
for more than ten hours.
These kids were on their way to school at
about 8:30 this morning local time.
They were commuting between two valleys.
Their school was on one side, their village
was on another, when this happened.
One cable snapped, there were already issues
regarding the rescue situation because of
the fact that the heli's blades were causing
winds which were causing that one cable that
was holding up that cable car a lot of to
move very frequently.
So again, those children were nauseated.
They dropped, in the commandos dropped in
antinausea meds we
[11:02:46 AM]
dropped in antinausea meds we were told by
one of the children, speaking to local media
from his phone.
That two of the children had vomited.
Another two were in and out of consciousness.
You have to realize this is a congested cage-like
contraption which is suspended mid air and
constantly moving by the winds, so it is now
completely night fall in that area.
It is still very ominous but there is a lot
of hope in this country that this rescue operation
will be suk secretary-- successful.
Becky?
>> And we are all praying for those who are
still trapped.
What have local authorities said about the
incident?
>> What we do know from people on the ground
is, is that there is a lot of support for
the commandos that are there on the ground.
There are a lot of people who have gathered
there.
We are being told that again while the rescue
operation by helicopter has stopped, they're
[11:03:48 AM]
helicopter has stopped, they're trying to
effort roaches, there is a lot of local knowledge
there because this is a difficult terrain
and the locals